je te dise la vérité
j'ai pas beaucoup de combler ses buts et
la tranquillité pas tremblé d'où ces
zones a et b toi ça va très bien je suis
très contente que tu fais les gens
adorent c'est vrai mais je te jour je
suis halluciné à chaque fois qu'on
mettrait autant de messages anti je dis
c'est pas pour moi enfin si en fait
c'est bah si tu le mérites voilà c'est
gentil merci beaucoup
poule c très gentil parce que c'est pas
facile de venir et partir comme ça plus
facile de rester toute l'émission
survenir comme ça faut être venir et
partir attendez il ya l'adoption fait
saint louis et rachid arhab j'avais web
et le tabac la semaine prochaine est
déjà gagné et bien alors on est habitué
à voir les chroniques et romain cyril en
marron par le chocolat et bien sûr lundi
en hommage à la république
ils ont été repeint en bleu blanc alors
parce qu'elle et ses mots ni vous poser
des questions pour tester votre culture
générale et pour vous aider la régie a
voulu utiliser les particuliers les
parties gradé de la table on a vécu un
nouveau drame
forcément c'est la banalise pas obligé
question sport concerné pays à organiser
la coupe du monde de football
de 1938 regarder la terre halluciné de
ces deux petites voix pour sembler être
aussi traumatisé et bien souvent ses
yeux c'est une boucherie
moi je suis sûr que ces prêts tous qui a
appuyé sur le bouton pour en mettre
plein la gilles verdez pour le
transformer en mn and rule géraldine
maillet qui jusqu'àlors n'avait jamais
reçu ne serait-ce qu'une goutte d'eau
sur la tête en quatre ans ces prix 300
litres de peinture bleue au point qu'on
a cru voir le sosie de la troupe peuvent
être regardés et puis regarder à gauche
autres invités le petit tchad et wendake
a eu la peur de sa courte vie il a peur
comme s'est vu valérie benaïm sans son
brushing
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
désolé je suis désolé les trois vraiment
mais je ne savais pas du tout où tous à
l'arrivée
moi j'ai fait une compte du gâteau
savait pas si tout le monde est logé à
la même enseigne assuré georges hardy ça
vous avez très bien ça va céline a été
mal gérée douches sont super au canal
factory du coup je me suis couché pour
la première fois grand c'est vrai nous
n'avons appelé personne
soraya et humide était là aux petits
soins et adorable avec moi mais elles
montrent bien des produits qui auraient
aimé eux aurait aimé prendre une douche
bon alors je lis très souvent justement
jean michel c'est une de mes idoles
pourquoi parce que c'est quand même
il est conscient lui que ça fait dix ans
qu'il est quand même payé à rien [ __ ]
non c'est vrai mais il est conscient 5
et fort
mais quand même c'est que c'est un
épicurien jean-michel il continue à
essayer d'amuser la galerie avec ses
vannes et comme d'hab
quand ses vannes ne passe pas cet été
magnifique alors c'est le retour du
petit jean-michel bien sûr le petit jean
michel a pris une grande décision pour
2011 pour être sûr de faire rigoler son
professeur il est chris evans à l'avance
oui non je rebondisse cas pas que maxime
plein d'infos petites infos médias le
journal du hard avance appelé les deux
coqs unienne de minuit
le petit jean michel2 perd jamais
confiance notamment quand il fait une
vanne et qu'il pense que tout le monde
va rigoler mais en fait non il n'a pas
vu que c'est le prince charles a gâché
passion à lyon pour un chat mais je
pense à la première fois de sa vie qu'on
l'appelle [ __ ] vous confiant lui
charles regardé comme le petit jean
michel a peur de son professeur le petit
jean michel et persévérant est prétexte
à faire des blagues et c'est encore un
succès une chute ce sera la réponse une
chute jamais jean-michel non ça a bien
marché
oui mais vous imaginez l'audience qu'ils
auraient pu faire si vous avez montré
des moines shaolin en train de se mettre
des suppositoires quand le professeur et
raymond ont ri ensemble d'une sortie de
route impressionnante
ça énerve le petit jean michel alors ils
participent et le regrette très vite au
lieu de crier du relais dans la voiture
et discutent pas qu'ils font des
tonneaux il t'arrive ça toi tu deviens
fou non ils sont en discussion est sûre
de la route l'eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai je suis ou disons toujours
pas compris qu'en lama n'est pas bon il
faut pas la répéter
il faut la répéter qu'elle soit avec les
pas mais quand je les entends du ca qui
n'était pas non plus je le sais vous
l'avez entendu must je retente quand
même continuer comme ça tant mieux pour
moi puis ça nous fait des séquences
demain je m'intéressais au coup de
pression devant michel crémieux c'est
l'extraordinaire franchement j'adore ça
alors voulais absolument revenir sur un
moment qui m'a beaucoup plu dans ma
lance-t-on poste après une pub se
demander ce qui vous arrive et syrie
parce que je n'ai jamais eu comme ça
vous étiez très essoufflé pour annoncer
la venue de nice en vous étiez souffler
comme si vous sortiez du marathon de
paris j'ai pas compris
alors ne manquez temps j'ai découvert
pourquoi vous étiez tellement essoufflé
que vous avez du mal à parler
regardez-moi ça et on a vu des choses
incroyables ce week-end enfin d'ailleurs
cette semaine avec les affrontements
entre montpellier et policiers va revoir
les images qu'on a vécu alors pourquoi
ça ils admettent aussi essoufflé kraft
nadal quand il répond à nelson monfort
après cinq heures de match en plein
cagnard sur le court central et l'est
parce que pendant la publicité comme
arlette chabot au cinéma se concentre
comme ça
[Musique]
l'insurgé pas résisté au regard des 1
d'autant qu'après ça vous soyez chrome
et cyril c'est pas possible nous dit on
vous dit
mais là la rigolade c'est relativement
des invités politiques en plus qui
arrivent à nous mêmes mais parfois il
son origine et ils voient les retours
c'est là que je vais aller alors non
t'inquiète pas tu inquiète pas c'est
normal ça c'est alors dans la vente
d'art cas vous avez avec une
chroniqueuse une grande caisse j'adore
c'est laurence peraud ah ouais moi je la
regarde tout en m6 boutique parce que
quand elle présente un produit elle le
fait tellement bien gentil tout acheter
d'ailleurs merci pour la grande marque
un record insanités de 806 mille
téléspectateurs
[Applaudissements]
elles vont tout espérons même les
sandales minceur sait qu'ils font perdre
trois kilos et ils auront dans la bande
barquettes je fais tout le temps vannes
et parce qu'elle n'a pas de mec elle a
jamais de mec alors quand elle avoue
qu'elle se fait draguer par une star de
l'humour ça donne une tête du
branchement veut peut-être sais je suis
tellement choqué que nous et la bouche
ouverte
c'est comme chaque mardi à vesoul baba
[Musique]
j'étais totalement libre et aussi on lit
s'est rien passé mais il ya eu un moment
de l'approché du hajj est fort
non j'adore ces thèmes nos invités dans
la grande marque si longtemps signalé
pascal là avec pascal légitimus way
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
pascal légitimus après ils auront spero
dems y soit parvenu mais un petit bail
maintenant ils se sont mariés mais genre
voilà il sait mais bien quoi j'ai à mon
avis le qui fait vrai sera de retour
samedi avec - lons pour j'espère et on
va compter sur un ben barka parce que la
semaine dernière laurent baffie elle
avait parlé d'une ex avoue connu que
vous avez qu'il avait décidé que l'on va
voir tout ce que je passe sur les
connais pas la détresse à l'évocation de
cette personne et vous aviez nie
l'existence et personne sauf que samedi
dans la demande arca il a recommencé
sauf que là je pense que votre réaction
là il ya plus de doute possible à part
tout nous dire si rien ne vous lâcherai
pas je partirai pas sans voix le
répertoire aux ménages de croiser une
copine
ouais et qu'il y ait un rapport avec toi
attendant question des jetons copine et
le hasard c'est qu'à la couche avec toi
aujourd'hui santé que le sujet vous
mettez très mal à l'aise et bien une
semaine plus tard laurent baffie d'euros
mais votre ex célèbre sur le tapis et
vous êtes encore plus de mal à l'aise là
mais la base est la copine à moi qui est
devenu par la suite arrête ne crois pas
à ça à rabat ne crois pas ouais c'est
qui alliera jours à lui-même en un jour
mais je dirai qui tu es dans l'oreille
peu après tu me diras tu fermes ta
gueule au brésil a dit l'europe
maintenant parce que j'adore comme ça
roule
j'aime bien ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
alors maintenant la france entière se
pose cette question mais qui est cette
femme mystère
[Musique]
je vous le jure vous pouvez demander à
laurent baffie il me l'a pas dit il ne
m'a jamais dit non et il faut pas me le
dire mais je pense c'est un énorme défi
qui va tenir comme ça pendant des
semaines et des semaines après voilà je
ne sais pas de qui ça il m'a dit que tu
es ya très très longtemps d'accord donc
moi j'écris ton nom mais j'ai quand on
m'a dit moi j'ai toujours c'est ce qu'on
entend bel je fais le dit rien mais on
attendait ce qui va me dire quoi
valérie damidot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va dire parce que alors mais
l'histoire de la belle avec valérie déjà
trouvé très mignonne
je le dis franchement et on était très
pote avec valérie et il ya très très
longtemps j'étais stagiaire et on avait
fait une soirée qui était organisé par
une grande boîte qui sape et endemol qui
a maintenant été racheté et il avait
fait une soirée où genre il a invité
tout le monde et c'était genre à
quelques kilomètres de paris avait des
tentes tout ça chacun dormi dans les
tentes en mai et il ya et valérie
damidot deux mois on sait mais bien non
on était potes
voilà ils ont rigolé on rigolait ont
rigolé et on se dit ouais on rigolade on
dit ouais on va dormir ensemble ce soir
mais on rigole alentours et à combien de
temps on était très peu trop chaud
quinze jours fera plus que deux en même
temps et valérie damidot était venu avec
une copine et finalement il ya la pluie
a un peu lisse pas toucher tout le monde
et je me suis pas retrouvé que valérie
damidot mais avec la copine de valérie
damidot bêêêê et la vie a fait que et la
vie a fait que il sema pas marouflé mais
tu vois comme quoi avec valérie il ya eu
il ya eu un bail mais c'est rigolo mais
il est très copain non je crois c'est
loin alors finalement n'était pas loin
et est tombé t3 valérie du tout pas très
convaincant voilà merci mais je vous
raconte tout ce temps je ne sais pas
bravo
[Applaudissements]
transparence veut d'irréprochable bah
oui bien sûr avec ce qu'il vous
connaissez pas ce que tu as les yeux
fermés je vois très bien la marraine de
valérie était célèbre non non non non
non non non non si je la connais ça
connais parce que je n'ai fréquenté
aussi figurez vous
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya beaucoup de jours sur peter
qui dit ce qu'est ce que c'est que cette
affaire avec laurent baffie dit que j'ai
chopé une copine à lui sachez que c'est
faux voilà je vous le dis les mêmes la
personne dont on parle est un art ce
n'est pas la bonne
non non non non non plus je n'ai rien
fait avec elle d'accord je vous le dis
moi je crois bamendjou dit voilà ce qu'à
lille et valérie damidot jules ambri
qu'est ce qu'il ya benjamin l'ethnisme
et fréquenté aussi c'est pas la bonne
personne c'était professionnelle si l'on
voit et je le dis aux téléspectateurs
énormément de sms ah oui oui c'est vrai
bah ça me fait plaisir que vous êtes
beaucoup
non mais j'aime beaucoup aussi bien
voilà c'est tout vous avez ramené c'est
quoi ce libye est parce qu on doit
parler de de funès exactement alors
c'est le scénario original de la folie
des grandeurs non jean à quoi bon groupe
et alors ça fait une semaine qu'on en
parle encore des points mais une
dernière chose là les choses dans la
vente d'art cas vous avez rendu jugé un
extrait de touche pas à mon poste où
vous recevez la chanteuse alex hepburn
oui et en sortie de magnéto vous n'avez
pas eu du mouzon vous portiez danse
magnéto à l'interview alors c'est un
blouson qui était un détail pour vous
mais pour d'autres ça veut dire beaucoup
ce blouson c'est que vous rafraîchir la
mémoire à propos de ce blouson cyril et
ça va faire du grabuge c'est quoi cette
histoire allait voir
[Musique]
hyper français je voulais te voir faire
la traduction être ça
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vendu soglo lazare or ce faisant
manifestement nous lisez pas le problème
c'est que moi je me souviens de comment
vous l'avez eu 12 ans et bizarrement une
boxe opposant avait l'air de beaucoup
vous plaire souvenez vous du 17 avril
2009 quand vous recevez le roux gaza
voire aux frais frais
plus et ça vous connaissez ses mac adam
levine
j'ai vendu soda
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vrai et joe lo qui est pour
vous le prouver vous savez ce que je
fais un show man
[Rires]
il est il est sur ma penderie vos ex
fasse mieux est ce que vous voulez que
j'essaie d'apporter le boulot avant que
j'ai c'est de ramener ce besoin dans la
bataille
mais c'est pas un jouet boulot et utah
moineaux
[Applaudissements]